What's up Marvel fans?
We're here with Jon Favreau,
who plays Happy Hogan.
Now you started
the MCU directing
Marvel Studios' "Iron Man."
What is it like to continue
that legacy of Iron Man
as Happy Hogan?
Well, I love being a
part of this as an actor
because I get to continue
to work with the people
that I work with on
the "Iron Man" films.
Also, even before I
started directing,
I remember visiting the
set of Spider-Man 3."
That was my first experience.
So it all feels-- it's nice
that it's all coming together.
And I'm just happy that I've
been able to be a part of it
in one way or another
for decades now.
That's awesome.
Well, now the entire world
knows who Spider-Man is.
How does that affect Happy?
Well, it's-- Happy has
always been in on the secret
with Tony Stark, with--
with Peter Parker.
So Happy was always good at
being a professional wingman
to help out and make-- help
them navigate their way
through all the challenges of--
of being a superhero.
I think he offers a
lot of moral support.
I don't think he's--
I don't think he's too
good for protection,
even though he's supposed
to be head of security.
But I think he's a good friend.
And I think for Peter
Parker, he was a good--
I think he took it
upon himself to look
after him after Tony was gone.
So I really like
playing that part.
And I really like
Tom Holland a lot.
And I love--
I love popping onto the
set and working with Jon
Watts and everybody there.
It's a great group
of young actors.
And as an actor, I love it.
And I think it comes
through in the character.
That's awesome.
Now do you have a favorite
MCU moment in Spider-Man
through your journey?
Oh, in Spider-Man, I like
when we're in the bathroom--
[LAUGHTER]
I think we're in the
bathroom together--
[LAUGHTER]
--where I'm trying to
be, like, Nick Fury
popping into his high school.
And I-- and I confront him.
[LAUGHTER]
And-- and someone
flushes the toilet.
So my really cool,
like, Nick Fury moment
is completely undermined by--
by a toilet flushing.
Yeah, I like that one a lot.
That's awesome.
Jon, thank you so much.
Enjoy the movie.
Thank you.
Have a good one.
[MUSIC PLAYING]